un utérus géant au coeur du village
rituel santé un outil pédagogique pour
sensibiliser les femmes à certains
risques notamment le cancer du col de
l'utérus
cette pathologie touche près de 3000
personnes en france par an malgré les
mesures de prévention de cette maladie
on le prévient de deux manières la
première c'est ce qu'on appelle la
prévention primaire c'est à dire éviter
qu'il y ait des lésions les lésions sont
liées à un virus qui est le
papillomavirus et il y à des vaccins
contre le papillomavirus donc qu'ils
évitent cette infection
et il y à la prévention secondaire qu'il
y ait au dépistage par frottis réguliers
nous sommes là pour parler de tous les
cancers gynécologiques et de la
prévention de ce que les femmes doivent
faire en amont ne pas se négliger et
régulièrement faire des examens faire
des contrôles ces préventions
s'inscrivent dans le cadre du village
éphémère rituel une dizaine
d'associations et de professionnels de
la santé avec comme marraine de
l'opération sandrine quétier
un événement organisé par hachette
prévention et le laboratoire msd dans le
cadre de la journée internationale des
droits des femmes
eh bien on va replacer la santé au coeur
des préoccupations des femmes les droits
des femmes c'est super important leur
santé aussi et c'est important qu'elles
prennent soin d'elle c'est pour ça que
le village rituel effectivement s'est
mis à exister en france d'après un
sondage ipsos 55% des femmes actives
estime avoir un état de forme inférieur
à 7 sur 10